[Musik]
durchgang und denn
ich schätze mal das gästezimmer
karin und stephan bolliger roller nach
litauen auswandern ihr traum von einer
ferienanlage startet mit viel schwung
und droht zu platzen
bringt alles farfan habe wüst ist was
auf einen zukommt schlechten zustand und
wird gar nicht startet
das ist die geschichte einer
auswanderung mit vielen hochs und tiefs
den hast du ja
[Musik]
karin bolliger arbeitet bei der
kantonspolizei zürich jemand stefan ist
abteilungsleiter in einer firma für
sicherheitstechnik sie haben in litauen
ein großes stück land gekauft mit dem
sie noch größere pläne haben
an vision ist dass es richtig mit war
mit blumen mit einzelnen bäumen wenn ein
paar kreativ los händler und auch in
waging am see flanieren und genießen
umsehe der sonnenuntergang hat müsse
ruhe und richtig ruhig wie man sowieso
in litauen 100 jahren was ist denn das
für das gefühl soll man
mich unbeschreiblich wie sich so viel
zeit vergangen
monat gelaufen ist und eigentlich immer
wieder für ski und deniz geschieht und
jetzt plötzlich passiert ist es sichtbar
oder wir sind so fest und schafft ein
grundstück kommunen und verbraucher wie
gleichheit im jahr nachholen
alleine jetzt plötzlich etwas machen
können ja
ich sehe mich unbeschreiblich
also
craxi
[Gelächter]
mallorca wenn es eine sehr stabile
serviert
stellt sich die frage wie die bolligers
darauf kommen nach litauen in ein
kleines land im baltikum auszuwandern
und wieso sie ausgerechnet hier in der
region annike rund zwei autostunden von
der hauptstadt vilnius entfernt also
ziemlich abgelegen eine ferienanlage
bauen wollen
[Musik]
nun angefangen hat alles auf einer
motorradtour
[Musik]
und ich ganze im blick der fachkreise
ich wohne gar nicht so dankbar sein
gedanke
also die gedanklich überhaupt nicht von
mir das leben wo platz ist kühler da
wollte ich wohne also
nicht
weg das ist so stark und so wirklich
wichtig und hat einen fotoapparat für
ihre kompletten ist meine tasche und
habe ihn
fertig gemacht wird genau darauf dass
ich mich erinnere war das ist und es ist
ja
irgendwie spezielles sie
der manta gedanken womöglich alles in
gang gebracht hätte was man jetzt
dauernd zu machen
ich habe das total fasziniert
natureplus
action indes an das land das eigentlich
habe ich gerade angefangen träumen und
gerade fünf fahrer für die ganze sache
lautet das ausland muss vorher bei den
bolligers sie haben land gesucht und
gefunden sie haben eine ferienanlage
konzipiert und business pläne entwickelt
und sie haben alle nötigen bewilligungen
eingeholt und mit dem bau zu beginnen
[Musik]
die blicke sind nach vilnius gefahren
sie wollen eine baumesse besuchen in
viele entscheidungen zu treffen
begleitet werden sie von ihrem bauführer
ramonas der ihnen helfen soll sich in
diesen unendlichen möglichkeiten einen
überblick zu verschaffen
[Musik]
böden bled die heizungen fenster überall
haben sie die qual der wahl
[Musik]
die zeile ganzes class budget für alte
sachen zu machen betroffene
bis zu einem gewissen punkt immer schon
flexibel aber
das müssen
aber
es geht wissen die fünfte sind einfach
wichtig die er
so die männer von der qualität her
stimmt stimmt das ganze konzept nicht
geht sind wir bereit zum egal
durchgehend anderes auch immer nach im
nachhinein fragt kann justieren oder
abbas die disney zwischenraum auch
liebes günstiges nimmt der fall
wie große budget genau ist wollen die
bolligers nicht verraten
klar ist sie stecken ihre ersparnisse
blogs pensionskosten gelder in ihren
traum
den komplexen stoff für einen
verschiedenen ist auch ein abschätzen
was man wann
konkret und küsse bruch nach haiti
im moment ist
man gespannt sein
all das alte sachen ich
ja umsetzen und die die taxe aufrichtig
sich die volksbank gescher bewusst
machte es nach einer anderen sport falls
sein falls den anderen lied ist schon
schwieriger also bin ich sicher acht
minuten nutzte sind die verleger
zu diesem zeitpunkt nennt bolligers noch
nicht was alles auf sie zukommen wird es
ist eine zeit des träumens und des
wünschens
wunsch
der hand dass
zusätzliche
teams oder bungalow hand das ist schön
gesteht dass wir angestellt die hand
personal hand ruhig bild ist
aber april
die hat es nicht geschafft dass man sich
entwickelt das man nicht stehen bleibt
und
einfach möglich dass das waren aus dem
cockpit ihnen ist dass das wirklich
greifbar und labor wird
das mit sprachen das mitspracherecht
fließen könne litauisch reden und ist
integriert hat und mit der lokalen
getreten
ja
das war das stichwort wäre
im moment haben die bolliger es noch
keinen festen ort zum schlafen darum
sind sie mit einem wohnwagen hierher
gekommen den sie auf dem grundstück von
die tauschen bekannten abstellen dürfen
er hat und merkt schnell dass man
eigentlich gar nicht viel bucht und sich
ein total wohl die frauen sind schön
anrichten
ich bin france
stefan hat seinen job in der schweiz
gekündigt karin noch nicht
[Musik]
sie arbeitet weiter beim forensischen
institut zürich
das karin
heißt du ein auftrag für mich
wenn irgendwo im kanton zürich ein
verbrechen begangen wird dann rückt sie
aus ihr auftrag vor ort spuren sicher
[Musik]
ob der brand in dieser tiefgarage mit
absicht gelegt wurde ist unklar die
ermittlungen werden zeigen ob wir
wirklich ein verbrechen vorliegt
sie schlug aus nach licht gebrannt durch
zufall dass immer besser mein
alltag wie im krimi den sie über alles
liebt darum fällt es ihr schwer ihre
arbeit aufzugeben
außerdem haben die banker so weiter ein
sicheres einkommen
die bolligers wohnen idyllisch in
hüntwangen zusammen mit zwei alpakas die
irgendwann ebenfalls nach litauen
umziehen sollen
premier league tor für st bei uns wohnen
und der und natur des gotthards dass
sich so einfach gut tut
stefan ist inzwischen die meiste zeit in
litauen und beaufsichtigt den bau kommt
aber immer wieder zu besuch
und karin ist meist hier aber auch immer
wieder in litauen ihr haus in wangen
wollen sie vorerst behalten
für den fall der fälle
vier monate nach baubeginn hat sich in
litauen bereits viel getan
für die politik läuft alles nach plan
in einer ersten phase soll nun ein
guesthouse mit fünf zimmern und einem
restaurant entstehen
das grundstück der bauliches liegt in
einer gegend die beliebt ist bei
städtern die ruhe und erholung suchen
es gibt dort schöne sache gegangen
aber natürlich nicht so viel also
schöne unterkunft und das schöne hotel
würde ich jetzt sage nach soll
aber direkt am see jetzt nur bisher
direkt umsetzen oder bisherigen jahr
mit anderen worten es gibt noch keine
angebote aber eine große nachfrage also
optimale voraussetzungen um mit ihrem
geschäft erfolg zu haben
die boni gestorben ein ganzes team an
gestellt das für den bau des gästehauses
zuständig ist und gut vorankommt
trotzdem ziehen dunkle wolken auf
denn ihnen droht schon bald das geld
auszugehen
[Musik]
kurze zeit
haben wird startet nach den küsten
finanzen hat die flüsse sind
jetzt mit flossen weil noch versichert
sind und das ist sich im moment eine
große
holtby wo man im moment dann
lage sind und am morgen und wohl schon
gedanken machte er zerrte verantwortlich
nicht nur für ihn also für ein für mich
sondern für mitarbeiter und wenn man so
bedankt man müsste jetzt gott sei dank
es tut uns leid im moment räume weiter
beschäftigen also es geht mir
einstiegswillige wird auf der baustelle
jeden tag die hand freut sich wirklich
super und man hätte sachlich bezogen
und auch natürlich plan warteten
irgendwo mit rosaroter ist aus
motivieren coach richtig sagte sven vom
zeitplan
musiker und vorwärts kommt aber auch
staaten und auch deine wiedergewählt
alles verfangen haben lustig war so
verzug und der
liechtenstein und die gar nicht statt
das als schweizer wo in sicherheit
gebracht
[Musik]
wie lange die boni kassieren arbeiter um
den lohn nachzahlen können ist unklar
und auch wie es mit dem projekt
insgesamt weitergeht ist offen
[Musik]
mit den nutzern und er zeige ich mir mit
zeigen die punkte
ich schwebe
einen hoffnungsschimmer gibt es
allerdings sie sind in kontakt gekommen
mit einem militärischen investor de
stellt ihnen große summen in aussicht
möchte aber einen überarbeiteten
businessplan bei den bolligers keimt
wieder hoffnung auf
ich wollte mir überlege dass diese
vision bleibt und durch die vorstellung
und ein traum bleibt und das
wird von mir und total andere
vorstellung jährige die oft krank waren
warten und das im rasierte stufe das
verhalten und ski zirkus mit dem partner
wo man da in aussicht hat dass der user
machen und
einfach unterstützend hilft ja
einen monat später steht die baustelle
der b liga still
denn ihr bauleiter hat ein burnout
und vom investor kommt kein geld
stefan wo die zwischen in einer art ein
haus auf dem grundstück und versucht
verzweifelt einen neuen bauleiter und
geld zu organisieren
karl ich statt jeder filter szenario
wenn das nicht passiert
können wir denn tun wenn es nicht
funktioniert wir machen was denn 41 sehe
ich es auch spannend also
sorry wie geht's weiter wenn co2
haben wir damals
lösungsmöglichkeit
stefan ist derzeit alleine in litauen
karies zurückgereist in die schweiz um
dort zu arbeiten
der winter steht vor der tür bevor der
schnee kommt müssen die bolligers
versuchen das dach fertig zu bekommen
und wände hoch zu ziehen
sonst könnte das bereits verbaute holz
schaden nehmen
ja ich es mag schon besuchs halte er
aber es ist wichtig dass es für den
winter nach einer taktischen offen
frosthart und allem dass das holz nach
als schütze dich haben die
gebäudereiniger sind fertig die sind ja
so behandelt dass man sich nach dem
gebäude innen aussieht
und
so mit schwarzem plastik aspekt dass sie
kein schaden an taktische wichtig dass
man bis zum ersten schnee und bis
gewinnt ich und ich und klima das wäre
es doch noch eine decke unbedingt
[Musik]
um die baustelle am laufen zu halten
brauchen die bolligers dringend liquide
mittel
ansonsten wird kein baumaterial mehr
geliefert und die arbeiter bleiben zu
hause
vielleicht ist der traum von einer
ferienanlage schon bald geplatzt
[Musik]
das projekt steht nun definitiv am
scheideweg
trotzdem lehnt stefan weiter fleißig
litauisch er sieht seine zukunft hier
und versucht positiv zu bleiben aber
gleichzeitig auch realistisch
[Musik]
österreicher verbringen vor dem internet
ich glaube du dich selber katrin und
plastik
ist mit den widrigen
notfallszenarien machen und weniger dass
man daran glaubte schneller die zweifel
auch wenn sie so war den könnte man
sagen versuchten dass ich mit aus
kriegszeiten es ist risiko wir versuchen
und was war vancouver sagte krzesinski
müsste man sagen ja auch weiß man nur
sagen es nicht versucht und das war
genau
[Musik]
ein halbes jahr später in hüntwangen es
ist frühling geworden und die bolligers
packen sie wollen ihre zelte in der
schweiz nun abbrechen und nach litauen
auswandern den dank darlehen von
verwandten und einem geheimnisvollen
schweizer investor der im dunkeln
bleiben will ist es ihnen gelungen das
projekt zu retten und ihr gasthaus einen
entscheidenden schritt voran zu bringen
vorsorge ich fertig
bleibt zurück super high zum guten
gewandelt dass man ein
investor gefunden hat und der
darlehensgeber und
in
gesetze entwickelt im januar
und den so im januar
eingeführt so richtig kann ich mal nach
litauen oder uni der druck immer rätsel
und kann man sich auf die zukunft
konzentrieren und
auf die wichtigen aufgaben wie das
bohren und nach das organisieren
versetzte
der dings sitzt gott zweiter und jetzt
da kein wunder das haus fertig können
wir den eröffnen im juni oder im juli
aber dann kommt das corona virus und
zwingt die welt in london zum showdown
grenzen werden geschlossen und das
öffentliche leben lahmgelegt und zwar
just in dem moment in dem die police von
der schweiz nach litauen ziehen wollen
irgendwo
ja es ist so kurz vorm groß dass man so
lange gewartet haben und so viel mal
durchgespielt haben im gros der knapp
also wie michael richter langer prozess
wie die aber nix da sie ja jetzt
möglichst freitag separat sie bis zum
jetzt gibt einfach noch mal ein stück
sowieso
schwierig zu akzeptieren
aber jetzt weiß ich was ich denn
plötzlich nur braucht ist plötzlich
alles
bis auf weiteres leben sie zwischen
kisten
gute zwei monate später hat das warten
ein ende die
kisten werden endlich bewegt
das blick auf
die grenzen sind passierbar und die
bolligers wollen die gunst der stunde
nutzen und den umzug über die bühne
bringen bevor sich die situation wieder
ändert
und wie ist die stimmung jetzt
wirklich haben lang lang wartet sich die
ganze pracht einfach ungewiss sie wenn
es für uns definitiv wieder gott wie
sieht's mit tränen haben wir sie stoppen
und den ganze haus eigentlich
froh dass es jetzt für ordnung ich fand
es eigentlich sehr
flow du doppelt der oberhausen oder
familie und freunde sind gekommen um die
bollig es beim umzug zu unterstützen
[Gelächter]
dass ich nur
für damen zwischen für diese frage
jetzt wird es erst
in drei wochen ein wenig nervös wird
alles klappt mitte habe mit der
fahrzeuge mit dem lautstarken und mit
dem ding sei
und jetzt
wirklich alles platz- und der cousine
bringt und ich wäre cool dass so viel in
kaluga halt von aber weiß natürlich
nicht wo wäre jede frage was muss ich
aber trage was muss ich machen soll
bitte auch schon
jetzt vielleicht fragen und den
unterschieden bei dem mit dem birkenhof
so kriegt
ihr haus wollen sie behalten um es zu
vermieten
zuerst wird nun aber ein ganzes leben in
einen riesigen lastwagen verladen und
auf die rund 1800 km lange reise
richtung osten geschickt
[Musik]
ein weiteres jahr ist ins land gegangen
so heißt die ferienanlage depot lag es
nun
sie ist nach fünf jahren planung und bau
inzwischen eröffnet
das gasthaus in betrieb
[Musik]
und stefan ist gerade darum das
frühstück für die gäste vorzubereiten
die kirche werden erst gegen mittag
eintreffen
darum muss der chef die gibt für mich
selbst in den ofen schieben
[Musik]
karin und ich mache so die e
springen wo es nicht verbraucht und
setzte plötzlich bin ich zufrieden
kritisch zum
morgen macht
unterstützen
grasser hat
im dritten monat nach der eröffnung ist
das kleine guesthouse mit seinen fünf
zimmern bereits zu 70 prozent
ausgelastet
wurde betrieb startet
gestartet
stefan
krauß und so endlich handeln so
dass man
versuchen sie freitag habe und das team
weist wenn was sie machen und
recht funktioniert so sucht befragung
hat es ist ja also das sagt sich so
wie man sich das vorstellt hätte
es gibt nur das müsse das café stellen
aber das ist wie immer wahrscheinlicher
[Musik]
ziel erreicht sagen die bürger sie
hätten eine wohlfühl oase geschaffen
ein kleines aber feines hideaway für
genießer und naturliebhaber inmitten von
wunderschöner natur direkt am see
gelegen
karin verbringt den sommer hier und
unterstützt die fünf angestellten
ihren job in der schweiz hat sie
allerdings noch nicht aufgegeben bis auf
weiteres will sie über den winter
jeweils bei der kantonspolizei zürich
als prinzipien im einsatz sein
wieso zwei verschiedene szenen aber
dass man ihm auch jetzt das mache ich
gern mitgliederschaft dass man jedes
schweiz macht man die polizei schafft
auch
nach dem frühstück bereitet karen die
zimmer für die nächsten gäste vor
dass sie ihren job in der schweiz noch
nicht gekündigt hat hat damit zu tun
dass sie ihn liebt aber nicht nur das
gästehaus ist zwar gut gestartet aber
wer weiß ob die bolliger ist nicht
plötzlich wie der frohsinn um ein
sicheres einkommen
dann klage geht es immer aber wenn man
in sein haus wenn ich es sehr beruhigend
und
investoren die ihr so langsam zurück
das konnte max theorie bis jetzt ist das
eigentlich noch nie kontakt
aktuell aber
jetzt selber im moment
so dass
nicht nur große sondern wirklich
verdammt habe ich das im moment gut dass
mich die zellen und fürsorge und den
kunden
natürlich sehen sehr erfreulich und gibt
also luft und ruhe und
harmonie hohem niveau dass ihre beiden
könnten normale
werte von
jeff fettig
stefan ist neben dem frühstück vor allem
auch für die ganze administration
zuständig oft wochen oder monatelang
ohne cory die zurückgeht in die schweiz
ich stell' ich es auch wir sind
schwimmer der
links ivo
fürer geschafft haben forschung haben
und keine gelehrt haben zusammen
drei schicht schaffe man im regen den
küsten und den haben oder wie sie zieht
mit den anderen den tisch stellen die
qualitäts zieht und stichsäge die anders
und mit der heutige
[Musik]
medienwirklichkeit
kommunizieren und klar ich bin ich schön
wenn wir zusammen sind und sammelt sind
verbringen
vorerst hat diese geschichte also ein
happy end ob das gästehaus soll nur der
anfang sein
in den kommenden jahren soll sich hier
eine ganze ferienanlage entwickeln
seit fünf jahren sind bolligers nun
schon auf dieser reise zusammen mit
ihren alpakas die inzwischen auch in die
town angekommen sind
auf einer reise die mit großen plänen
und viel schwung begonnen hat
auf einer reise mit vielen höhen und
tiefen und mit ungewissem ausgang
was danke der jury für
uns bedeutet
das ist immer eine interessante frau
ja immer noch da
ja genau schön pflegt pflanze beim
größten gern
ein paar eimer ist schöne rose
auf beinahe
fertig genau
die keb ins nahe und mein haus
eigentlich so eine gesunde größe
habe mit allem was an tand ja
und wie drin gestellt die unter
vorgestellt
da